nuevas tensiones en la frontera chileno
peruana donde decenas de migrantes
continúan varados e intentan sin mucho
éxito cruzar al lado peruano en el
momento
la capacidad operativa de dos puestos
que se encontraban ingresaron pero
fueron este reconducidos en la línea de
frontera según un decreto oficial Lima
mantendrá por 60 días más el estado de
emergencia con el despliegue militar y
policial para reforzar el control
fronterizo mientras los migrantes en su
mayoría venezolanos y haitianos intentan
regresar a pie a su país de origen
tampoco me voy a ir por por el desierto
ni banda corriendo porque no soy ningún
delincuente verdad y como ser humano yo
merezco la oportunidad de llegar a mi
destino a mi país Nadie puede negarme el
derecho a llegar a mi casa el jueves
luego de las tensiones entre migrantes y
fuerzas de seguridad en tacna la
cancillería peruana reiteró a las
autoridades chilenas garantizar la
seguridad de su territorio e impedir el
bloqueo de la carretera Panamericana
mostrando un gran descontento ante la
supuesta falta de colaboración del
ejecutivo chileno el Ministerio de
relaciones exteriores convocó al
embajador de chile en Perú para
expresarle su protesta por la falta de
colaboración mostrada por las
autoridades policiales chilenas la cual
ha generado los acontecimientos
producidos hoy la cancillería chilena
también citó al embajador peruano
después de que el alcalde de tacna
tildara a Gabriel boric de irresponsable
organizaciones humanitarias como
amnistía internacional urgen a ambos
países a poner fin a la militarización
de las fronteras como respuesta al
ingreso de personas en necesidad de
protección internacional acusando a los
gobiernos de ambos países de agravar la
situación humanitaria